[Music]
if you've been paying attention to the
news you've noticed that
amber he's coming what
this is not a drill he is on the way no
oh my god no you're kidding what's going
on
i'm serious someone said they just saw
him get off the f train
who who just got off the f train tarik
broadway
jack is coming broadway jack
broadway jack broadway
jack the most amazing talented charming
creature the world has ever known
i always thought he was just a legend oh
no he's real
i heard he once punched a man so hard
his hair
instantly turned gray broadway jack
i heard he started world war one by
telling the joke so funny
it made archduke franz ferdinand laugh
himself to death
broadway jack i heard he was secretly
married to mariah carey for three years
but he ended things because she got too
clingy
she never got over broadway check
i heard he's not allowed to walk down
the street in 12 different states
because
he's so hot he fogs up all the windows
broadway check brad pitt mentioned
broadway
jack at the oscars last year he said i
want to thank broadway
jack god and then whoever made this
movie
in that order broadway jack
my friends baby saw broadway jack on the
street once and said her first words
those words were oh damn that's broadway
mother
jack broadway i can't believe it
why is he even coming here i don't know
maybe they're going to give him his own
show
oh that would be so awesome i would
totally watch the broadway jack show
oh my god tarik what is it did something
bad hap
oh no this can't be happening
nope i don't want to know i'm in too
good of a move for any bad news broadway
jack is coming here
there is nothing you can say that could
ruin my day
broadway jack is dead
no why god why
i can't believe this does does your
alert say how broadway jack died
no it says the details are still coming
in
why do the good always die young
why do you give your toughest challenges
to your strongest soldiers god
i bet he died saving a bus full of
school children from speeding into a
volcano
and the volcano was full of knives
broadway
check i bet he died doing surgery on
himself
to give his heart to someone who really
needed like the pope or
his clingy ex-wife mariah carey broadway
jack i bet he died cause god was jealous
of him
broadway check well no matter how he
died
the world is worse off without him i
speak for all of us at the amber ruffin
show and i say
he was a hero and he will be missed
goodbye broadway jack
[Music]
[Applause]
you